le concorde avec deux heures de retard
emmené les employés de michelin au
dessus de l'atlantique qu'ils avaient
travaillé à l'amélioration des pneus de
l'avion mais pas de chance c'est un
circuit hydraulique qui a provoqué le
retard au décollage le froid perturbe la
circulation sur les grands axes routiers
vers l'espagne l'autoroute a9 est
toujours fermée encore ce sont quelques
douze mille foyers qui n'ont toujours
pas d'électricité
à bruxelles les cases réunion ce maire
désigné valéry giscard d'estaing comme
le président de la convention chargée de
préparer l'avenir de l'europe et
notamment l'élargissement de l'union
éloges unanimes de la classe politique
française valéry giscard d'estaing est
l'invité de ce journal la tour de pise
réouverte au public douze ans de travaux
et 25 millions de dollars pour restaurer
l la halle des plus célèbres monuments
italiens
et puis nous rendrons bien sûr hommage à
claude de santé vie qui nous a quittés
une figure emblématique de la télévision
auteur dramatique producteur et
réalisateur
madame monsieur bonsoir le froid
toujours très vif perturbent la
circulation sur quelques grands axes
routiers dans le sud du pays
ce sont les camions qui sont les plus
pénalisés sur l'autoroute a9 dans les
pyrénées-orientales le poste frontière
vers l'espagne est toujours fermé un
millier de poids lourds faisait ce matin
du surplace reportage véronique gaglione
n'est pas ce qu'elle pense leur seul
point commun c'est qu'ils veulent tous
aller en espagne leur malheur c'est que
la frontière est fermée
alors depuis ce matin ils attendent
chauffeur routier pour la plupart mais
aussi particuliers ou touristes pourquoi
rester ici pour toujours
on arrive un jour ici la fin
l'après-midi vous allez sortir de
l'autoroute voilà l'essentiel que je
n'arrive à perpignan pour que les gens
puissent mangera là autour de perpignan
il y a eu jusqu'à 15 km de bouchons
aujourd'hui ici 250 camions par heure
prennent la route de l'espagne la
frontière est sous la neige
alors depuis nîmes déjà on tente de
dissuader les chauffeurs de continuer
leur route ils sont priés de s'arrêter
et d'attendre ils ont chois enfin et ils
n'ont pas trop le choix
maintenant vu le nombre et après que
cinq échappés
c'est toujours au plus mal et je vais
sortir la sibérie nos marques je vais
prouver pour la nationale et on verra si
on ne peut pas passer des métaux et
l'énergie qu'ils restent sur l'autoroute
ou et c'est la nationale les chauffeurs
finissent tous sur un parking ou une
aire de repos
les particuliers ont été dégagés des
bouchons reste cinq à six mille routiers
qu'ils ne gagneront pas l'espagne et
dormiront entre nîmes et le perthus
même si la frontière s'ouvre tout
doucement ce soir de l'autre côté de
toute façon les routes sont bloquées par
la neige et plusieurs heures de retard
pour des tgv qui assure la ligne
bordeaux paris en raison de la rupture
de caténaire le froid serait à l'origine
de cet incident une circulation alternée
a été rétablie en fin d'après-midi et
des températures qui ont souvent
avoisiner les -15 degrés cette nuit de
fortes gelées au lever du jour avec des
routes de verglacer à marseille
opérations de salage sur les grands axes
le plan neige déclenché hier soir dans
les hautes-pyrénées la haute-garonne
empêcher la circulation des poids lourds
entre pau et toulouse encore se
maintenait son sens plus de douze mille
foyers qui sont toujours privés
d'électricité la neige depuis hier isole
de nombreux villages
edf n'envisage un retour à la normale
qu'en début de semaine prochaine et
encore si la situation météo ne se
détériore pas nombreuses interventions
des pompiers de m'attendre
la corse comme on ne l'avait pas vu
depuis bientôt dix ans un mètre
cinquante de neige par endroits et de
nombreux villages en altitude rendu
inaccessible dans la nuit les fortes
précipitations ont arraché des lignes
électriques par dizaines aujourd'hui
onze mille foyers sont ainsi privés de
courant pour tenter de faire face
edf a mis en place une cellule de crise
il ya encore des endroits où nous
n'avons pas accédé les hélicos n'a pas
pu décoller et donc jusqu'à ce matin
nous nous étions sur certains sur
certaines parties du réseau dans
l'inconnu
chez les pompiers de haute-corse le
standard est assailli d'appels depuis ce
matin la priorité absolue a été donnée
aux personnes âgées coincé dans les
zones reculées du département malgré les
véhicules tout terrain certains secteurs
restent encore difficiles d'accès un
sens cette annonce est bon mais tous les
assauts souvent des recettes août à
beaucaire
selon météo france les précipitations
devraient nettement s'estomper dans les
prochaines heures
demain une centaine d'agents
d'intervention d'edf devrait arriver sur
l'île le retour au service normal est
prévu pour le début de la semaine
l'espagne touchée par de très fortes
chutes de neige là aussi le thermomètre
est descendu largement au dessous de
zéro
parmi les 14 régions concernées c'est la
catalogne qui connaît une situation la
plus critique
comme à barcelone où de nombreuses
coupures de courant étaient enregistrés
routes verglacées qui ont provoqué de
graves accidents
contrairement aux idées reçues un temps
froid et sec est mauvais pour la santé
en particulier pour les asthmatiques
selon les spécialistes les virus
continuera à se développer explications
audrey goutard dessine de tri nous
sommes nombreux à le croire un bon froid
sec comme celui de ces derniers jours
protège de la maladie les microbes se
développe plus sur les pêcheurs sur le
pays froid ça c'est clair
oui ou 1-0 il ya patrick rumeurs cette
idée reçue à la dent dure
même les professionnels de la santé en
sont convaincus le froid tue les
microbes dans sont souvent faites ce qui
les fait proliférer c'est la chaleur et
l'humidité donc on conseille par exemple
aux gens qu'ils ont
en jeans perrin d'ouvrir les fenêtres
d'aérer souvent mais tout cela serait
faux de récentes études le démontrent
très clairement les virus nathan drake
une chose pour se réveiller et attaquer
que la température baisse
le froid a une incidence plutôt négatif
sur sur les épidémies de grippe et de
gastro-entérite puisque ces virus
prolifèrent et se réactive
particulièrement quand il fait froid et
sec
ce n'est pas tout ces temps ci les
asthmatiques se bousculent dans le
cabinet du docteur contrairement aux
idées reçues aux aussi sont
particulièrement sensibles à ce temps
froid
c'est le cas de benjamin ça a commencé
en fait est qu'il a commencé à faire le
froid sec mauvais pour la santé c'est
une claque aux croyances
quant à ses nageurs nordique il sera
difficile de refroidir leurs ardeurs
eux sont convaincus qu'ils prennent là
un bain de jouvence
l'apparition des premiers kits en euro
continue de réjouir les français qui se
sont rués désir chez les buralistes
notamment après leur eau des villes
voyant leurs eaux des champs avec
l'exemple dans une petite ville de la
creuse un peu plus de 5000 habitants
pris par le froid et qui découvrent à
leur tour les premiers euros françois
privat philippe ritaine
- 7° à la souterraine dans la creuse et
l'événement du jour c'est qui fait voir
si tout ce que je pars ou bien via que
les auront bien que ça l'événement du
jour et puis le froid était un café et
ils vont tous sans chercher d euros ici
au bureau de poste
on peut rien dire rien faire comme si on
n'a pas les pièces sonnantes et
trébuchantes au pourboire pour comparer
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire grandir
se mette au courant de l'euro c'est bien
joli mais si vous avez rien les pièces
ne semblent pas aussi bien frappé que
que les les pièces en francs qu'on avait
jusqu'à maintenant ça me fait penser un
petit peu aux pièces de savez qu'il ya
dans les jeux sont les gamins sa fait
les pièces en presque en chocolat et
pour chaque kit euros ht un beau verte'
soeur offert à quelques jours de noël
ça donne forcément des idées des clients
alors enfin leurs petits-enfants leur
fille elle pour papin entre époux ça
vaut pas un diamant remuant fin au bar
tabac
on parle aussi euros mais parmi ses
clients personne n'a acheté son petit
c'est s'empresser sont prêts c'est moche
je le porte en moi deux doigts sont
obligés d'unir
du meilleur ou d'une autre ça soit du
jour avant ouais je vois pas bien la
différence maintenant avec nous sans
euros en poche dans les rues de la
souterraine
il fait toujours aussi froid après
l'accueil enthousiaste de la france
c'était au tour des italiens espagnols
le belge ou finlandais de découvrir les
premiers euros en autriche hier soir un
train de l'euro et avait sillonné tout
le pays ces dernières semaines est entré
sous les ovations des orifices dans la
gare centrale de la capitale avec
distribution à minuit pile des kits en
euros je propose à présent ce reportage
tout à fait inédit houle ensuite du
début à la fin
le processus de fabrication de l'euro 52
milliards de pièces ont déjà été
fabriquées dans 12 pays
voici comment reportage david beeri à la
location de leur eau liquide
tout commence dans ses fourneaux à plus
de 800 degrés pour leur nouvelle monnaie
les européens ont mis au point un
alliage à base de cuivre
le nordique gold un métal couleur or
dans cet atelier de la région parisienne
des kilomètres de bobines sont
soigneusement débité en confettis
c'est ce qu'on appelle des flux
monétaires on en retrouve notamment ici
à bruxelles
dans ce lieu sensible placée sous haute
sécurité vient vous êtes maintenant dans
l'atelier principal de la monnaie royale
de belgique
où on produit les euros c'est l'un des
15 centres de production en europe dans
ces lourds chariot d euros belge
flambant neuf les fleurs monétaires sont
frappés dans ces machines 3 à 4 millions
d'exemplaires par jour pour arriver à
tenir la cadence
il a fallu utiliser de nouvelles
techniques au départ on a eu quelques
problèmes je vis de mise en jambes
étant donné que nous n'avions jamais
travaillé à ce genre de pièce et qui
sont partis d'une feuille blanche
nous avons devenu naturellement pas mal
travaillé sur la fabrication des crèmes
en des terres est sûre je veux dire le
réglage des machines à partir du moment
où nous avons trouvé le bon plan b sans
abri poser de gros problèmes j'habite
depuis deux ans et demi
il manipule tous les jours cette
nouvelle monnaie pourtant même pour ces
professionnels
l'euro n'a pas que des avantages les
pays européens donc dans ce registre au
profit d'un autre côté des prix assurent
sans beaucoup d'eau je trouve que ce
sera un petit peu moins profité de ce
progrès lents mais les européens devront
apprendre très vite à reconnaître les
quelques 52 milliards de pièces qui
circuleront dans leur force mené à
partir de janvier prochain politique
avec la convention nationale du parti
socialiste qui investit ses candidats
pour les prochaines législatives
ces accords concernent également les
verts et les radicaux de gauche voici
les prévisions du nombre des
circonscriptions pour les candidats du
ps 504 circonscription quarante et une
pour les candidats levèrent 32 pour les
radicaux de gauche
l'examen d'une trentaine de
circonscriptions délicate sera reportée
ou gelé dans l'immédiat et puis à noter
sur l'agenda que les verts se
prononceront le 13 janvier prochain sur
cet accord qu'ils considèrent pour
l'instant comme insuffisant lui et
repère fête ses 25 ans d'existence un
parcours parfois tumultueux pour ce
parti fondé par jacques chirac demain
rassemblement des militants et les
grands ténors à la tribune porte de
versailles bernadette chirac pourrait
peut-être faire le déplacement c'est une
rumeur retour à présent avec laurent
hakim sur ce quart de siècle riche en
péripéties et rebondissements
jacques chirac président le 5 décembre
76 jacques chirac est déjà président
président du rpr qu'il vient de fonder
le nouveau sanctuaire des gaullistes
il s'adresse aux militants comme on
s'adresse à une nation 76 c'est surtout
la rupture avec la maison giscard après
deux ans à matignon jacques chirac vient
de claquer la porte
77 sera sa revanche chirac décroche la
mairie de paris face au candidat
giscardien mais cette rivalité giscard
chirac est promise à l'échec que l'on
sait après la gifle la reconquête en 86
le président du rpr et le copilote de la
première cohabitation mais la gauche
aura le dernier mot à la présidentielle
premières dissensions chez les
gaullistes souvient d'assises du
mouvement on avait mis aux voix
différentes motions la tente du résultat
n'était pas vraiment très agréable pour
ce que l étions pas habitués à cette
culture de courant 93 le sursaut
électorale amène edouard balladur à
matignon la rivalité avec jacques chirac
et met en péril la présidentielle je
vous demande de vous arrêter
finalement chirac est à l'elysée mais un
événement fait chanceler le pouvoir des
gaullistes
j'ai décidé de dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale
à l'assemblée le rpr est décimée dans
les instances gaulliste c'est un jeu de
massacre à la jupe et abandonne le
mouvement à philippe séguin à la mairie
de paris le putsch toulon fait long feu
charles pasqua préfère suivre philippe
de villiers et à la veille des
européennes sarkozy doit reprendre en
catastrophe
la direction des opérations oui la
soirée du 13 juin 99 de respect comme un
beau sommet décembre 99 michèle alliot
marie devient le quatrième président du
rpr depuis jacques chirac une bataille
sanglante seul le glas du fr à la mairie
de paris défaite cuisante pour les
initiés séguin ce que je souhaiterais
pour l'avenir c'est ne pas être dans la
situation du pompier
qui va dans une cité banlieue qui se
fait caillasser à son art a lieu
aujourd'hui dans certains scénarios
c'est la mort du rpr qui semble
programmé à sa place l'union en
mouvement rassemblerait les familles de
la droite n'est pas disparaître du jour
au lendemain
même si certains traités mais rien ne se
fera sans l'aval de jacques chirac qui
reste 25 ans plus tard la référence du
parti gaulliste et puis ce sondage qui
teste la popularité du chef de l'état et
du premier ministre
une popularité stable pour jacques
chirac pour lionel jospin avec 54%
d'opinions favorables pour le président
de la république et 43 % pour le premier
ministre les deux hommes enregistrent
une forte hausse de pignons négative
selon ifop journal du dimanche et lionel
jospin réuni plus de mécontents que de
satisfaits puisqu'ils sont 45% à
désapprouver l'action du chef du
gouvernement
en afghanistan les premières éditions
des combattants fidèles à ben laden les
troupes américaines continuent leur
offensive
selon le quotidien le washington times
la voix de ben laden aurait été repéré
par les militaires autrement dit il
serait toujours bel et bien dans la
région reportage philippe rochot sylvain
siou
sous les bombardements américains 300
combattants arabes résiste encore mais
il serait prêt à se rendre 50 déjà se
seraient livrés mais nous n'avons pu les
voir les tchétchènes sont les plus
déterminés et veulent continuer à se
battre
les tchétchènes sont dit-on les
protecteurs de ben laden et ne se
rendront pas leur chef et il avait que
les afghans continuent de penser qu'il a
quitté la place de tora bora
nous sommes à ben laden est parti d'ici
avec des gens d'al qaïda
peut-être que les autres ont accepté de
négocier mais les terroristes sont finis
régulièrement les afghans capte des
conversations en arabe et les livre aux
américains
vous aurez ainsi identifié la voix de
ben laden qui d'après eux se trouverait
donc encore ici les américains sont très
actifs dans les airs mais aussi au sol
près de 150 commando héliporté se battre
est ici avec les moudjahidine mais ils
ne veulent pas être vus ce sont eux
pourtant qu'il cueilleront les
terroristes d'al qaïda
s'ils finissent par se rend les
bombardements américains et la riposte
d'el qaïda avait poussé sur les routes
des centaines de personnes avec le recul
du front certaines reviennent au moins
pour être chez elle en cette fin de
ramadan la fête musulmane de l'aïd
devrait profiter ou combattants d'al
qaïda pendant les deux jours qui
viennent les combattants afghans
n'auront guère le coeur à se battre en
revanche les bombardements américains ne
s'arrêteront pas au sud de l'afghanistan
maintenant les détenus de la prison de
kandahar ont été progressivement libéré
aujourd'hui
est ce donc une semaine après la
capitulation des talibans qui tenait la
ville nous ont envoyés spéciaux que son
père et gilles jacquier ont pu pénétrer
à l'intérieur de cette prison avant que
ne soient ouvertes les portes du
pénitencier
si l'unique prison de kandahar avant la
reddition des talibans vendredi dernier
la ville comptait vingt mille membres
d'al qaeda plus de 60000 talibans nous
sommes venus ici pour voir combien
avaient été invités les gardiens nous
emmène tout d'abord voir les prisonniers
arabes ont pensé rencontrer des hommes
de ben laden
interpellé récemment et à notre grande
surprise on découvre que tous ces hommes
ont été mis en prison sous le régime
taliban et al abadi celui des six riante
il est accusé d'espionnage
celui là vient d'arabie saoudite
il a aussi été arrêté par les talibans
il était accusé d'être un agent de la
cia ne comprend ce qui lui arrive
aujourd'hui en fait les nouveaux patrons
de kandahar veulent faire croire à la
presse qu'ils sont tous des combattants
arabes
en vérité il n'ya ici aucun membre d'al
qaïda ce que confirme en toute
tranquillité
le chef des gardiens le cas et le
commando n'ont pas là dans la partie
centrale de la prison la cour des
miracles ici et sauvegarder tous les
prisonniers afghans
on les interroge depuis les murs
d'enceinte les talibans et sont pas là a
dit celui ci en a pas un seul
on les a pas vus vous savez la seule
chose qui a changé ici c'est qu'il n'y a
plus de torture c'est tout où sont
passés les taliban de kandahar alors que
nous suivons la dernière ronde des
gardiens dans nos têtes beaucoup de
questions
cette ville a été le fief des talibans
pendant sept ans et aucun d'entre eux
n'a été arrêté
avant de partir le directeur de la
prison nous dira même le mot l'homme
un grand homme un bon musulman les
nouveaux maîtres de l'afghanistan sont
décidément bien difficile à comprendre
pour un occidental
l'armée israélienne poursuit son
offensive dans la bande de gaza et
l'occupé la ville palestinienne de bêta
nous la population et face aux chars de
tsahal chalendar c'est la première fois
que l'armée israëlienne réoccupe ainsi
une localité autonome dans la bande de
gaza un secteur où la densité de
population est une des plus élevées au
monde
55% des habitants est ici moins de 15
ans et le combat est inégal fusils
d'assaut kalachnikov cocktails molotov
et pierres contre des chars
la riposte
trois jeunes de 12 15 et 16 ans ont été
tués ainsi qu'un policier palestinien
il n'y avait en fin de journée 75
blessés plusieurs casemates
officiellement l'opération israélienne
est destiné à capturer des terroristes
et à saisir des armes
la maison d'un chef de la branche armée
du hamas a été détruite
il n'a pas été fait prisonnier cette
offensive terrestre doublé de
bombardements aériens a été déclenchée
il ya trois jours après l'attaqué par
leur ramasse d'un bus transportant des
colons en cisjordanie un attentat qui a
fait 10 morts
il serait bien l'armée israélienne s'est
retirée en début de soirée dub et rano à
ce stade rien ne semble pouvoir arrêter
cette guerre qui ne dit pas son nom
hier soir au conseil de sécurité des
nations unies le délégué américain
opposé son veto à une résolution
prévoyant un cessez-le-feu et l'envoi
d'observateurs internationaux en
cisjordanie et à gaza et la fin du
ramadan qui sera célébrée demain
notamment par les musulmans de france
après un mois de jeûne et de préparation
à la fête comme dans cette famille qui
via coop à bruxelles cet après midi au
sud de la ville une manifestation contre
le sommet de mai qu'elle a généré
plusieurs centaines de personnes
antimondialisation parmi lesquels des
anarchistes ceux qui s'en sont pris aux
vitrines et aux voitures les quinze
réunions se met à laquelle n'ont désigné
en fin de matinée valéry giscard
d'estaing présidente de la future
convention pour l'avenir de l'europe
valéry giscard d'estaing qui est notre
invité sa nomination a été très
largement saluée en européen convaincu
qui oeuvrait depuis tant d'années pour
la construction de l'europe
christian mary mono didier renquet le
candidat de la france valéry giscard
d'estaing était soutenu par les grands
pays
il a donc été nommé président de la
convention l'axé franco allemand a
parfaitement fonctionné
une irlande est également candidat ou
une coque s'était éclipsé l italie avait
retiré son candidat
la présence belge cache mal son
agacement je ne connais pas
personnellement mais je pense pas on m'a
pas fait rapport sus des handicaps que
monsieur giscard d'estaing a et
deuxièmement il a bien entouré le
président de la convention sur
l'architecte de l'europe à 27
il dispose d'une feuille de route la
déclaration de laquelle elle se fait
l'interprète des questions des citoyens
qui fait quoi
il ya urgence ce n'est plus du
ravalement c'est un nouveau chantier ici
on joue les prolongations en raison de
tensions de dernière minute mais
avantage pour la france avec la
nomination du président giscard
d'estaing à la tête de la convention
européenne jusqu'à destin bonsoir oui
des loges quelle belle unanimité à votre
désignation ce sujet sur pause jacques
chirac s'en félicite lionel jospin s'en
félicite et moi on est à fond les jeux
on t'appelait tous les deux de bruxelles
et ont raconté comment les choses
s'étaient passées alors ceci nous permet
vous envahir venir d'évacuer donc la
question qui agace ou qui peut fâcher la
question de votre âge
que répondez vous à ceux qui ont évoqué
une erreur de casting pour l'avenir de
l'europe en projet d'abord faire un
petit calcul très rapide de géra de
gaulle a été élu président la république
française pour la première fois en 1965
il est né en 1890 il avait donc 75 ans
c'est mon âge et chats quelqu'un qui
souhaiteraient être plus jeunes c'est
pas les autres
chez moi on objectera que vous à
soutenir dès le début vous ne verrez
plus non au début il d'abord je n'étais
pas candidat au début on l'a attendu un
peu on a regardé ce que ce que c'était
que cette convention et on a pensé j'ai
pensé qu'il serait important que ce soit
un français
c'est ça la première idée un français
parce que nous sommes à l'origine de
l'idée européenne
rappelez-vous jean monnet et robert
schuman vous moi mais bon et donc comme
on va définir
nouvelle europe l'europe du 21e siècle
et le bon convention c'est assez fort
les conventions révisées tout le monde
pour des piles à ce qu'on va faire
penser que ça serait bon que ce soit en
france m alors on verra si derrière ce
mot convention ya pas que des bonnes
attentions va essayer d'aller par étapes
d'abord à ceux qui pourraient douter
encore de votre belle vitalité je
rappellerai que c'est vous l'année
dernière qui avait soulevé le problème
du quinquennat on a l'impression que
c'est un peu chaque année valéry giscard
d'estaing l'incontournable il ya deux
semaines vous étiez quasiment candidat à
la présidentielle vous n'aviez pas
demander une chose où il passe une
phrase de churchill pas qu'il est en
politique il faut jamais rien exclure
ce qu'on ne sait pas ce qui se passe en
réalité par exemple m'interroger sur ce
sujet avant le 11-septembre personnel
prévu long septembre si bien qu'en
politique il faut avoir la sagesse de
dire on n'exclut pas les soirs c'est une
divine surprise
enfin c'est pas tout à fait une surprise
que ça a été préparée il s'était préparé
par les représentants français ça donne
le président de la république le premier
ministre
notre diplomatie ça a été très soutenue
par nos partenaires allemands qui ont
été très loyaux dans cette affaire
depuis le début cette ses soutiens uci
par nos amis méditerranéen
les italiens espagnols qui sont engagés
dans cette affaire mais d'autres pays de
toutes tailles un pays comme l'autre
échappé comme le luxembourg ou en paix
comme l'irlande ont apporté leur soutien
avec l'arrivée de l'euro on
al'impression quasiment la jour pour
jour à 24 heures près vous avez le
sentiment que c'est un bon présage
entre vous et pour l'heure un bon pour
moi laissons les gens sur le côté on
parle de l'europe l'a d'abord l'arrivée
de l'euro c'est la fin d'une époque
en fait c'est ce qu'on a essayé de faire
depuis 1950 jusqu'à 2000 on a essayé de
bâtir l'europe et lui donner une monnaie
le repas s'est donné aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs intéressant de voir comme les
français se sont précipités sur les
euros et les autres européens o'shea
donc quand on dit me les gens
s'intéressent pas ils sont à différents
ils ont il faut que ce soit concret
qu'il comprenne et on y fait des choses
parce que je vais citer par exemple
c'est le texte précis de la déclaration
de laeken
qui dit à un moment et j'ai suscité
cette phrase donne hilaliens fossé qui
se creuse
entre les citoyens et les institutions
européennes jugées trop tentaculaire
donc comment vous allez réduire ce fossé
parce que c'est vrai qu'il existe oui
bon il ya ce fossé alors essayons dire
des choses tout à fait simple il ya une
première époque c'était l'époque de
l'europe de l'ouest
on a essayé d'organiser leur réussit à
l'organiser on l'a dotée d'un parlement
élu au suffrage universel
on a créé le conseil européen qui réunit
elle les cognacs chasser les créations
on lui a donné une monnaie puisqu'on
peut aller aujourd'hui dans les cas
étaient pas dans les banques dans les
poches
on me donne la monnaie européenne donc
cette première étape a été un succès et
puis la grande idée affreuse de de
l'europe jusqu'au jusqu'en 1945 c'était
la guerre alors disparu venons
aujourd'hui voyant surtout l'avenir
là tout à coup on bascule nouveau siècle
siècle réunification de l'allemagne est
arrivée des nouveaux pays qui étaient
sous la poigne de fer de l'union
soviétique
donc nouvelle europe et cette nouvelle
europe
il faut l'organiser alors le point
important c'est de savoir qu'est ce que
les gens attendent de l'europe et je
dirais pendant les trois prochains mois
cette convention je lui proposerais mois
de rechercher ce que les gens attendent
de l'europe qu'est ce qu'ils veulent on
va voir s'ils attendent la même chose et
quelle façon sont d'âge de conversations
faut prendre tous les moyens leurs
drones et qu'est ce que vous attendez de
l'europe
ensuite quand on aura des filets on
verra ce qu'ils ont comme ainsi lors
devant le fond commune et moi je crois
qu'à des moments de communes il demande
la paix il devant une certaine sécurité
il demande la prospérité ils veulent la
tolérance qu'on pût en europe qu'elle
soit une région tolérance donc une
région du monde particulière en fait une
fois qu'on aura défini les attentes
d'europe
je n'avais comme en répondant à ses
attentes qu'est ce qu'on met en place
pour répondre à ces attentes entre des
dc ou est ce un gros défi serait pas
seul il faut pas super g que sans
travail change faire du neuf bâtir sur
des bases nouvelles
oui c'est ça votre idée il n'y a pas de
précédent historique
c'est ce que les joueurs ont dit les
états unis les états unis quand ils sont
fatigués de tête 3 millions d'habitants
plus son look
de dire 700 mille esclaves 3 millions
d'habitants nous on va être 400 millions
les américains jettent à tous de même
origine parlaient la même langue nous ne
sommes pas tous les mêmes origines
parlant des langues différentes des
modes de vie différente
donc ça veut dire que l'exercice est
beaucoup plus difficile mais en même
temps il faut le réussir
on sera là pour poursuivre et peut-être
une dernière question un peu plus
poétique à ceux qui secrètement se
réjouissent que vous soyez peut-être
hors-jeu dans la campagne électorale à
venir vous répondez quoi j'aurais donc
la main pour se consacrer à ce qu'on
fait à partir du moment où c'est un
travail à plein temps un travail qui
vous absorbe je vais me consacrer à ce
travail de façon intense je reste un
citoyen français et comme citoyen
français je participerai aux choix
politiques de la france merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
les employés de michelin à bord du
concorde pour un tour au dessus de
l'atlantique un voyage récompense pour
ceux qui ont travaillé sur les nouveau
pneu du supersonique mais voilà que
concorde a pris du retard en raison
d'une panne ou plus exactement d'un
circuit hydraulique défectueux un petit
incident qui vient s'ajouter à d'autres
rien est essentielle mais une série qui
donne un envol difficile aux nouveaux
concours de stéphane despinoy maya lui
ce n'est le concorde est décidément via
capricieux cette fois c'est une fuite
hydraulique qui l'a cloué au sol tuyaux
tri défectueuse le supersonique n'a
vraiment pas la baraka
la fête avait pourtant bien commencé
divin d'hommes bombant le torse sur la
passerelle 70 salariés invités un vol
d'exception après trois heures de
réparation le commandant de bord a dû
plaider le mauvais concours de
circonstances
j'ai pas comment je vais demain
transparence que je le fais
l'équipe est armée s'attendent man ça
tombe mal
ça tombe d'autant plus mal que ce n'est
pas le premier pépin technique depuis la
reprise des vols le 7 novembre
avant cette fuite il y avait notamment
un feu de tuyères le tuyau d'échappement
du concorde à 16h enfin le supersonique
d'école face au puy de dôme et à bord la
tension a redoublé
concorde aura finalement réaliser sa
boucle sur l'atlantique comme prévu
il faut dire qu'à france avait pris
toutes ses précautions en envoyant à
clermont ferrand ses meilleurs
techniciens manifestation à paris de
parents souhaitant adopter des enfants
essentiellement vietnam et qui sont
descendus dans la rue pour arriver à un
déblocage rapide des dossiers en cours
en effet depuis quelques mois voire
quelques années leur dossier n'avance
pas car les autorités souhaite moraliser
et changer les procédures d'adoption
reportage aguerris genna françois
meunier berne numério il y a longtemps
déjà que pour eux l'adoption s'est
imposé comme l'évidence leur choix
c'était le vietnam alors il ya deux ans
ils ont constitué leur dossier auprès de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance
alten sens et dans ce dossier il y à
toute leur vie ils ont répondu à toutes
les questions même les plus indiscrètes
ils ont vu des psychologues et puis ils
ont obtenu leur agrément
c'est à dire l'autorisation d'adopter un
enfant au vietnam
les voilà depuis il attendre vu l'enfant
n'est toujours pas là ils ne comprennent
pas pourquoi il s'est déjà passé un an
quand vous avez votre dossier de
constitué uniquement
vous avez déjà un an qu'elle se passer
moi ce qui me met en rage c'est que on a
passé cette année là à faire exactement
comme comme vous ne l'avez demandé
on a suivi les règles on a suivi les
procédures et que maintenant deux ans
pratiquement se sont passées et que le
dossier n'est même pas atteindre féline
à vous on a même le sentiment que ça
risque d'être complètement annulé quoi
c'est le sentiment qui ressort de pas du
peu de d'élément concret qu'on a vu sa
vie de du ministère le désarroi pour
1342 candidats à l'adoption dont les
dossiers sont aujourd'hui bloqués il est
vrai qu'en 1999 l'adoption au vietnam
avait été suspendu mais elle a repris en
l'an 2000 rien ne s'opposait donc plus à
ce que les français adoptent des enfants
vietnamiens
le gouvernement avait d'ailleurs promis
aux familles déjà inscrits d'accélérer
le processus
et puis le mois dernier ce fut le coup
de théâtre
c'est un coup de massue parce que dans
un premier temps madame ségolène royal
vous avez dit tout faire pour débloquer
rapidement des dossiers qui avait suivi
un cheminement parfaitement normal
aux termes de la convention signée avec
le vietnam et le lait novembre elle nous
dit les familles devront peut être faire
leur deuil de l'adoption
tout au moins au vietnam dans les
ministères on prétexte qu'il n'y aurait
pas assez d'enfants adoptés au vietnam
on dit aussi qu'il faudrait de nouvelles
procédures d'adoption pour moraliser les
filières mais alors pourquoi dans ces
conditions at ont permis à ces familles
d'espérer peut pas leur dire non on n'a
pas le droit ya pas un texte qui nous
autorise à leur dire ça ne sera jamais
espéré les gens d'en décider non nous
sommes très clairs nous sommes
extrêmement clair nous leur disons nous
les décourageant par tous les moyens
soyons très clairs mais décourageons par
tous les moyens faux rétorquent que les
familles jamais distel on ne les a
dissuadés de postuler sur le vietnam des
familles qui aujourd'hui exige donc des
réponses plus claires dans les zones
urbaines sensibles dès l'année prochaine
les gardiens d'immeubles ferons nous
referont leur apparition
selon un projet de la secrétaire d'état
au logement marie noëlle lienemann un
gardien pour cent le juin sera désormais
obligatoire une façon de rendre plus
humaine la vie dans les cités
l'exemple dans le quartier de loos près
de lille ou décharger d'entretien et de
maintenance sont aux côtés des gens du
quartier
marianne masse de nick masse dans les
sous-sols de la barre d'immeuble c'est
lui le gardien des clés local poubelles
cave local d'entretien qui rit est ici
chez lui depuis six ans il est chargé
d'entretien et de maintenance
on peut voir à pharmacie pour le
problème donc tout ce que les embauches
de cadres tels que quelqu'un dise d
euros si on peut les appeler pour un
petit un petit truc qui ne va pas dans
l'appartement et ils viennent pas c'est
vrai qu'ils dépassent leur fonction m'a
dit voilà
mais ils sont toujours là on peut les
appeler à pas de problème entretien des
espaces verts maintenance ménages des
parties communes dans le quartier ils
sont 14 comme thierry pour s'occuper de
1250 logements
il habite sur place et sont rémunérés
directement par l'office gestionnaire de
l'immeuble
les concierges qui n'en sont pas
vraiment mais leur présence rassure il
ya beaucoup moins de dégradations tout
le monde de les locataires sont mordus
content et j'ai fait d'une façon tout à
fait différente que par le biais de
l'entreprise par exemple et pour les
locataires ce service à un coût environ
100 francs prélevés chaque mois sur les
charges on est plus en sécurité en fait
on sent qu'à quelqu'un quand même qu'on
peut aller chercher que disent tous ces
gens comme eux qui frappe la sécurité
ils connaissent le monde dont plus de
moi ça leur permet de dire qu'il faut
dégager des appartements en tous sens le
décret gouvernemental prévoit la
présence d'un gardien pour cent le vin
dans les zones sensibles dès le 1er
janvier prochain les bailleurs sociaux
ont donc du pain sur la planche
quant à thierry il continuera à rendre
service toutes sortes de services à
lorient le but route du fipol qui
s'occupe de l'indemnisation des victimes
de la marée noire de l'erika a été
détruit par le président de la
confédération maritime qui est en guerre
depuis deux ans pour qu'enfin soient
correctement indemnisé des victimes
une opération vandalisme que revendique
à la malardé qui a été placé en garde à
vue en italie après onze ans de
restauration la réouverture de la tour
de piste pour le plus grand plaisir des
touristes la tour mondialement célèbre
et est construite sur un sol sablonneux
et instable et on craignait qu'elle ne
s'écroule 24 millions d'euros plus tard
ils ont été nécessaires pour redonner
vie à la tour julien boom
le conservateur s'y est repris à deux
fois onze ans que la porte de la tour de
pise n'avaient pas été ouvertes au
public
en cause un penchant un peu trop
prononcé l'édifice menacé de s'effondrer
aujourd'hui aucun risque pour ces
touristes privilégiés
visites guidées et gratuites en avant
première ça fait vraiment quelque chose
d'être ici c'est la première fois que je
me trouve en haut de la pile bon c'est
vrai il fait un peu frisquet mais vu
l'importance de l'événement je supporte
le froid sans problème
seuls les groupes limité à 30 personnes
pour profiter de la vue unique sur le
baptistère et la cathédrale coût de
l'entrée 15 euros 8 fois plus qu'il ya
onze ans une augmentation jugée
nécessaire vu la facture des travaux 24
millions d'euros
à ce prix là la nappe phréatique sous la
tour a été comblée avec du plomb le
monument s'est redressé de 40 cm d'après
les prévisions et les évaluations du
comité la tour doit avoir une durée de
vie d'au moins 300 ans
c'est même vous qui est plus jeune que
moi vous ne serez pas là pour vérifier
mes dires
une seconde vie pour la tour de piste
construite en 173 déjà à l'époque elle
penchait dangereusement
enfin tout dépend comme on la regarde du
sport en 32e de finale de la coupe de
france de football
victoire de bastia face à nantes 3 ce
sont deux équipes de première division
voici donc le plus beau but de bastia
parmi les autres résultats surprise avec
la défaite d'auxerre face à saint-priest
déception pour caen battu par la
montagnarde club de division d'honneur
en revanche aucun problème pour
marseille qui a battu saint leu 2 à 0 au
stade de vélodrome
la disparition d'une personnalité
emblématique de la télévision claude
santelli auteur dramatique réalisateur
et producteur de temps d'émission est
décédé ce matin des suites d'un accident
survenu mi septembre sous le chapiteau
du cirque gruss alors qu'il travaillait
à la mise en scène de la flûte enchantée
jacques chirac rend ce soir hommage à
l'une des figures les plus éminentes et
talentueuse de la télévision michel
c'est le dernier spectacle imaginé par
claude santelli la flûte enchantée de
mozart jouée par les artistes du cirque
gruss faire partager par le plus grand
nombre les joies de la culture ce fut la
ligne de force de toute sa vie
avec comme outil privilégié la
télévision l'isoc qui à l'époque était
une baisse de creuser formidable arriver
des gens tous les horizons où en étaient
tous ceux amis et où chacun cherchait
son destin dans par rapport à un
instrument en train de m c'est à dire
que l'on pouvait à la fois pratique et
surtout inventer claude santelli
c'était un conteur hors pair grâce à ses
émissions les grands auteurs maupassant
hugo dickens cervantes devenait nous
familier ce château il le place victor
hugo dans la forêt de fougères là en
plein centre et la france
révolutionnaire et il savait avec
fourgons être et délicatesse être un
rassembleur de talent il avoue les faits
qu cela je vous impose rien on va voir
je place mon contrat les voilà avec lui
les grands classiques devenait le livre
de chevet de la télévision tout santelli
pour nous c'est l'honneur de la
profession c'est la dignité de la
profession
c'est l'homme qui auteur
et comédien aussi à ses débuts puis
réalisateur a toujours cherché à toucher
le public avec des moyens dignes et
l'estiment pour claude santelli toucher
toutes les générations les plus jeunes
comme ici romane bohringer admirait le
créateur et participer à ces aventures
oman m'a dit j'ai essayé de le proposer
des choses mais elle savait très bien ce
qu'elle voulait a dit boris vian il a
toujours été quelqu'un de du côté de la
création du côté d'une envie d'une
télévision populaire culturel accessible
à tous
au service d'un humanisme à partager
claude santelli pas mariée toute sa vie
l'intelligence il y aura j'espère mine
ce journal on rappelle les deux
principaux titres le froid perturbaient
la circulation sur les grands axes
routiers vers l'espagne l'autoroute a9
est toujours fermée encore ce sens
quelques douze mille foyers qui n'ont
toujours pas d'électricité
à bruxelles les quinze réunis en sommet
ont désigné valéry giscard d'estaing
comme présidente de la convention
chargée de préparer l'avenir de l'europe
et notamment l'élargissement de l'union
éloges unanimes de la classe politique
française dans un instant la météo
isabelle martinez 20h50 c'est show
présenté par patrick sébastien de master
dans thé ou café catherine ceylac que
reçoit le chanteur marc lavoine quant à
moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
dès 13 heures demain je vous remercie de
votre attention
excellente 500 et son concert